[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend wir bringen
Sie in den kommenden 20 Minuten auf den
neuesten nachrichtenstand die vom Sport
hat Norbert Lehmann heute
Handschlag unter Rivalen die Präsidenten
der USA und China's beenden nach
jahrelanger Eiszeit ihre Gesprächspause
Festnahme in Istanbul eine Syrerin soll
den Bombenanschlag gestern verübt haben
Ermittler beschuldigen die kurdische PKK
und Mission WM-Titel mit einer
menschenrechtsbotschaft an Bord startet
das deutsche Fußballteam Richtung Katha
[Musik]
wir beginnen auf Bali mit Spannung war
das Treffen von US-Präsident beiden mit
Chinas staatschechien erwartet worden
einen Tag vor dem G20-Gipfel die beiden
Großmächte sind wirtschaftlich und
militärisch Rivalen ihr Verhältnis ist
zu rüttet überraschende Annäherung heute
sie wollen ihre Zusammenarbeit in der
Klimapolitik wieder aufnehmen und beide
verurteilen die russische Drogen mit dem
Einsatz von Atomwaffen in der Ukraine
eine Gellinek
die gipfelkulisse auf der Ferieninsel
Bali maximal traumhaft der Zustand der
G20 des Clubs der 20 wichtigsten
Industrie- und Schwellenländer maximal
kompliziert noch bevor der Gipfel morgen
losgeht treffen sich der amerikanische
und der chinesische Präsident um
Klartext zu reden das erste Gespräch von
Angesicht zu Angesicht seit fünf Jahren
in denen sich die Rivalität zwischen den
USA und China weiter zuspitzte
wir müssen unseren Beziehungen jetzt
eine Richtung nach vorn geben und sie
weiterentwickeln drei Stunden setzen die
beiden zusammen und besprechen die
jeweiligen roten Linien das China
aufrüstet und Taiwan bedroht dass die
USA Chinas Wirtschaft mit Strafzöllen
und Exportkontrollen hemmen und vor
allem dass China zusammen mit Russland
eine anti-westliche allianzformt
immerhin hier eine kleine Bewegung
wir haben über die russische Aggression
gegen die Ukraine gesprochen und waren
uns einig dass die Drohung Nuklearwaffen
einzusetzen absolut inakzeptabel ist
dieser Satz soll auch in der
Abschlusserklärung des Gipfels
Auftauchen der russische Außenminister
sergeylavroff ist ebenfalls schon da
nach offenbar kurzem
Krankenhausaufenthalt auf Bali
verbreitet das russische
Außenministerium eilig Bilder des
Ministers in Shorts und T-Shirt auch
ohne putin ist die Haltung der
russischen Delegation klar jede Kritik
am ukrainekrieg soll abgewehrt werden
die Frage vor der Traumkulisse von Bali
ist also ob es dem anti-westlichen Lager
gelingt den G20 Club weiter zu spalten
fangen wir MRT wissen vor Ort was ist
ihre Bilanz dieses persönlichen Treffens
zwischen beiden und hier
besser als erwartet also wenn man tachel
ist redet sich gegenseitig die Meinung
sagt dann ist er immer das Risiko da
dass es eskaliert aber heute war das
Gegenteil der Fall man ist sich einig
dass man sich uneins ist bei Themen wie
Taiwan Menschenrechte Handelsbarrieren
aber beide haben kein Interesse daran
einen neuen Kalten Krieg zu führen weil
darunter ihre Wirtschaft leiden würde
und deswegen gibt es jetzt
Arbeitsgruppen auf kabinettsebene da
will man Themen angehen wie Klimawandel
pandemiebekämpfung aber auch die
Lieferketten Engpässe aufzulösen und
dann eben das Signal an Moskau dass man
ganz klar sagt Atomwaffen dürfen nicht
genutzt werden und es darf auch deren
Einsatz nicht angedroht werden und China
geht wahrscheinlich noch einen Schritt
weiter wir hören aus Diplomatenkreisen
das China bereit ist in der
Abschlusserklärung den Satz mit zu
unterschreiben der sagt dass Russland
oder ein Krieg in der jetzt Zeit einfach
nicht mehr geschehen darf und wenn China
das tut dann wäre das Ergebnis dieses
Gipfels sicherlich am Ende viel besser
als erwartet Dankeschön für diese
Einschätzung live aus Bali war das
emmativ wissen
wie isoliert steht Russland vor dem
G20-Gipfel da dieser Frage geht auch der
Livestream der ZDF heute live um 19 Uhr
nach
auch der Bundeskanzler ist inzwischen
auf Bali eingetroffen zuvor war Scholz
in Singapur auf einer
asien-pazifik-konferenz der deutschen
Wirtschaft gemeinsam mit
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck warb er dort
für intensivere Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
um die deutsche Abhängigkeit von China
zu verringern Norman Odenthal berichtet
Singapur steht blendend da der
Stadtstaat bietet stabile Verhältnisse
bewältigt Krisen zuverlässig ist damit
attraktiv für alle Welt auch für
deutsche Unternehmen mehr als 2100 sind
hier niedergelassen und dabei soll es
nicht bleiben der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister macht Werbung
auf der Asien Pazifik Konferenz Singapur
ist eigentlich ein idealer Startpunkt um
weitere Geschäftsbeziehungen aufzubauen
also das was wir immer Diversifizierung
nennen nicht nur alle Karten auf China
setzen sondern andere Räume zu finden
ist sicherlich das große Thema dieser
Konferenz und grund genug dass ich hier
auch bin das ist er nicht allein für ein
paar Stunden macht auch Olaf Scholz hier
Station Bundeskanzler und Vizekanzler
gleichzeitig im kleinen Stadtstaat
deutlicher kann Berlin seine asiatischen
Ambitionen nicht machen Ambitionen die
eben nicht nur auf den Riesen China
bauen ausdrücklich nicht
wir kommen gut mit China zurecht können
gut mit China handeln aber wir müssen
darauf achten dass wir unsere
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen und Lieferketten
vielseitig berichten und unsere eigenen
Kompetenzen behaupten
Singapur hat den zweitgrößten Hafen der
Welt ein echtes Pfund der heimischen
Wirtschaft schnell kommt da wieder in
Erinnerung das Bundeskanzler und
Wirtschaftsminister sich jüngst nicht
immer einig waren von Chinas Beteiligung
am Terminal in Hamburg bis zur
kanzlerreise nach Peking heute klang das
schon eher nach einer gemeinsamen
Strategie sie lautet Asien ist mehr als
China belohnt wurde dafür nur einer
Singapur widmet seinen höchsten
Staatsgästen gern eine Orchidee
renantera Olaf Scholz der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister ging was das angeht
leer aus
nach Deutschland die Union hat das
Bürgergeld im Bundesrat vorerst gestoppt
der Vorwurf das neue Gesetz schaffe zu
wenig Anreize nach Arbeit zu suchen das
machen die Kritiker vor allem an zwei
Punkten fest in der sogenannten
vertrauenszeit von sechs Monaten sollen
Leistungen nur in wenigen Fällen gekürzt
werden und ein gewisses Vermögen bliebe
zwei Jahre lang unangetastet für
Alleinstehende 60.000 Euro und für jede
weitere Person 30.000 Euro Lars brunsack
berichtet
dass die Union im Bundesrat blockieren
wird kommt nicht wirklich überraschend
seit Wochen streiten Regierungen
Opposition übers Bürgergeld die Fronten
sind verhärtet jetzt muss der
Arbeitsminister auf den
Vermittlungsausschuss hoffen alle werden
sich bewegen müssen das ist deswegen
Wesen von Kompromissen und bei guten
Willen gelingt es auch meiner Pell nur
an alle ist wirklich guten Willens zu
sein jetzt kann es nicht um
parteipolitische Spielchen oder um
Blockaden gehen sondern es geht um
sachgerechte Lösungen und bei guten
Willen aller Beteiligter wird uns auch
gelingen während sich einige
Unionsländer eine Annäherung bei
Karenzzeiten und vermögenshöhe
vorstellen können lehnt Bayern das
Bürgergeld kategorisch ab
das Gesetz ist nach unserer Überzeugung
ist und bleibt das falsche Signal zur
falschen Zeit wir brauchen eine gerechte
Balance zwischen denen die Leistungen
bekommen und denen die sie mit ihren
Steuern möglich machen die Ampel wird
wohl auf die Union zugehen müssen und
deutet an wie eine Kompromisslinie aus
ihrer Sicht aussehen könnte wir können
das konstruktiv wenden und das
Bürgergeld noch besser machen also
Klarstellungen beim arbeitsanreiz durch
Mitwirkungspflichten oder auch durch die
Verbesserung der
Zuverdienstmöglichkeiten wenn Menschen
fleißig sind würde ich sehr begrüßen das
würde das Bürgergeld insgesamt besser
machen nicht einmal zwei Wochen Zeit hat
der Vermittlungsausschuss ein Kompromiss
zu finden andernfalls wird es wohl kein
Bürgergeld zum ersten Januar geben
in Deutschland durften Lebensmittel wohl
noch teurer werden die Erzeugerpreise in
der Landwirtschaft steigen weiter an im
September lagen sie umfasst 40 Prozent
höher als ein Jahr zuvor laut
Statistischen Bundesamt verteuerten sich
besonders Speisekartoffeln um 73 Prozent
Getreide stieg um 41 Prozent bei den
Tierprodukten zogen die Milchpreise mit
knapp 58% am stärksten an
zum Krieg in der Ukraine dort hat
Präsident selenski die Stadt Herr Sonne
im Süden des Landes besucht nur wenige
Tage nach dem Rückzug der russischen
Armee
die Stadt mit ehemals
280.000 Einwohnern ist strategisch von
großer Bedeutung den Rückzug der Russen
auf die andere Seite des niepro nennt
selensky den Anfang vom Ende des Krieges
Dara Hassan sané konnte sich im
befreiten Person umsehen
die Menschen sind noch immer von ihren
Gefühlen übermannt in ferson gibt es
keinen Strom kein Wasser aber seit drei
Tagen seit dem Rückzug der russischen
Armee haben sie ihre Stadt wieder zurück
wir sind jetzt frei und die Ukraine wird
frei wir glauben daran und wir warten
bis wir das Böse vollständig besiegt
haben
ist noch nicht vollständig entmint und
blickt in Reichweite der russischen
Artillerie die Einschläge sind klar
vernehmbar
und trotzdem ist selensky heute in die
Stadt gekommen
das ist erst der Anfang vom Ende des
Krieges denn man kann sehen wie stark
unsere Armee ist Schritt für Schritt
holen wir uns die besetzten Gebiete
zurück
viele Geschäfte sind geschlossen manche
wurden von russischen Soldaten geblündet
wie diese Apotheke alona verkauft ohne
Strom im Dunkeln was sie noch auf Lager
hat es ist nicht mehr viel
wir sind glücklich weil unsere Soldaten
da sind
wir haben gewartet so lange gewartet
die Kunden kommen jetzt noch weil wir
immer noch etwas im Sortiment haben
wir sind glücklich
und doch wissen die Menschen in herson
dass sie wohl ohne humanitäre Hilfe
nicht auskommen werden aber immerhin ein
behelfsmast für Mobilfunk ist heute
schon in Betrieb
da der ukrainische Präsident spricht von
hunderten von Kriegsverbrechen in den
zurückeroberten Gebieten sie waren heute
dort können Sie das bestätigen
wir haben mit einem ukrainischen
Aktivisten gesprochen und er hat uns
geschildert wie vier seiner Freunde in
einem Keller gefoltert wurden und einer
seiner Freunde sei Zeit dem verschwunden
zudem hat die ukrainische Polizei jetzt
bestätigt dass auf einem Friedhof Spuren
gefunden wurden die auf einen Massengrab
hindeuten weil alles weitere werden die
Ermittlungen der nächsten Tage und
Wochen ergeben aber wenn man sich
anschaut wie in den anderen befreiten
Gebieten Kriegsverbrechen aufgetreten
sind und Massengräber gefunden wurden
dann ist Schlimmes zu befürchten
dankeschön
weitere Unterstützung erhält die Ukraine
von der Europäischen Union die
Außenminister der EU haben sich darauf
geeinigt rund 15.000 ukrainische
Soldaten auszubilden auch in Deutschland
darüber hinaus beschlossen die
Außenminister neue Sanktionen gegen Iran
wegen der andauernden brutalen
Unterdrückung von Protesten zu den
Maßnahmen zählen weitere Einreiseverbote
und das Einfrieren von Vermögen
das Gasunternehmen sefe wird
verstaatlicht das Teil des
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium mit grund
sei eine drohende Insolvenz der
ehemaligen Tochter des russischen
gazprom-konzerns seefe sei ein
schlüsselunternehmen für die
Versorgungssicherheit in Deutschland es
steht bereits seit April unter
Treuhänderschaft der Bundesnetzagentur
Deutschland fällt beim Klimaschutz
weiter zurück das geht aus dem
klimaschutzindex hervor den die
Organisation German watch mit
Wissenschaftlern erstellt
für die Top Ten reicht es in Europa für
die nordischen Länder Dänemark Schweden
Estland und Norwegen Deutschland rutscht
auf Platz 16 von den rund 60 Staaten mit
den meisten Emissionen die Top 3 bleiben
komplett unbesetzt Begründung kein Land
setzte sich genug dafür ein die
Erderwärmung auf 1,5 Grad zu begrenzen
die Details hat Marco
die Welt beim Klimaschutz zieht sie noch
immer nicht an einem Strang zum Start in
die entscheidende Woche in Sharm
el-Sheikh macht das der globale
klimaschutzindex deutlich Deutschland
ist dabei nur in besseren Mittelfeld
verschlechtert sich sogar das liegt
daran dass zum einen zwar die
Klimapolitik der ampelregierung besser
bewertet worden ist als in der
Vorgängerregierung aber die Klimapolitik
der Vorgängerregierung noch dazu führt
dass die erneuerbaren Energien
eingebrochen sind und die Emissionen
nicht so schnell sinken wie sie
eigentlich sinken sollten insbesondere
im Verkehrssektor auch der Ausbau der
flüssiggasimporte in der Energiekrise
und das Hochfahren von Kohlekraftwerken
trüben die deutsche Bilanz immerhin
positive Signale in Sharm el Sheikh von
entwicklungsministerin Svenja Schulze
sie gab den offiziellen Startschuss für
einen globalen Schutzschirm er soll
armen Ländern bei klimabedingten
Katastrophen rasch helfen 170 Millionen
Euro stellt dafür Deutschland Zeit ein
Anfang das Signal was wir mit dem
globalen Schutzschirm gegen
klimarrisiken hier senden ist dass wir
Brücken bauen wollen zwischen den
Industriestaaten und denjenigen die
jetzt schon am schlimmsten vom
Klimawandel betroffen sind der Schirm
eine erste Hilfe für arme Länder die
selbst kaum zur Erderwärmung beitragen
über Konzepte die Ihnen dauerhaft helfen
sollen wird auf der Welt Klimakonferenz
in dieser Woche noch hart verhandelt
nachdem Bombenanschlag in Istanbul
melden die Behörden schnelle
Fahndungserfolge dutzende Menschen
wurden festgenommen darunter sei auch
die mutmaßliche Attentäterin eine
Syrerin sie soll Verbindungen zu
kurdischen Milizen haben bei der
Explosion waren sechs Menschen getötet
und mehr als 80 verletzt worden aus
Istanbul Lück valpot
die Opfer des Anschlags wurden heute in
Istanbul beigesetzt unter ihnen auch
eine 15-jährige Schülerin die zusammen
mit ihrer Mutter getötet wurde
Angehörige und Freunde in tiefer
trauert es wäre vielleicht eine
Verwechslung aber wir konnten sie nicht
erreichen dann hat unser Lehrer uns
informiert
überraschend schnell präsentierte die
Polizei heute früh Fahndungserfolge mehr
als 40 Festnahmen darunter die
angebliche Hauptverdächtige eine Syrerin
die die Bombe platziert haben soll die
Frau soll gestanden haben ihren Auftrag
direkt von kurdischen Milizen im
nordsyrischen Kubaner erhalten zu haben
für den türkischen Innenminister solidu
ist damit klar die kurdische terrormiliz
PKK ist der Drahtzieher solo machte auch
den NATO-Verbündeten USA
mitverantwortlich weil Washington mit
kurdischen Milizen in Syrien
zusammenarbeite
die Allianz mit einem Staat der in
kobane Terroristen auch finanziell
unterstützt und damit unseren Frieden
versucht zu stören muss von uns jetzt in
aller Deutlichkeit in Frage gestellt
werden
sowohl die kurdischen Milizen in
Nordsyrien als auch die pkk-wiesen in
Stellungnahmen im Internet jede
Beteiligung an dem Anschlag zurück im
Gedenken an die Opfer ließen die
Behörden heute entlang der
Einkaufsstraße in Istanbul türkische
Flaggen aufstellen
wir kommen zum Sport zur
Fußballnationalmannschaft die ist
unterwegs ja am Mittag in Frankfurt
gestartet DFB und Lufthansa mit einer
gemeinsamen politischen Botschaft
Diversität gewinnt das Team von Hansi
Flick landet gleich im Oman dort ein
Trainingslager letzte WM Vorbereitungen
Testspiel inklusive für Trainer und Team
beginnt die wm-mission mit großen
Hoffnungen doch ohne den Erkrankten mag
andritter Stegen der aber nachreisen
soll es geht nicht nur um Titel und Tore
und so trägt der Flieger auch den
Schriftzug diversity wins Vielfalt siegt
besonders für die Wahrung der
Menschenrechte wollen sie Zeichen setzen
wir werden natürlich in enger Absprache
mit dem DFB immer schauen natürlich wie
weit kann man gehen wir machen uns
Gedanken darüber und werden unsere Werte
vertreten sie wollen sich auch
gesellschaftspolitisch positionieren und
so warten auf und neben dem Platz
besondere Herausforderungen bei dieser
Reise ins Ungewisse
zur Fußball-Nationalmannschaft der
Frauen die hat heute Nacht ihr zweites
Testspiel in den USA gegen die USA
verloren in der 18 minute brachte Jule
Brandt das DFB-Team vor 26.000
Zuschauern in Ford Lauderdale in Führung
ja danach aber der Doppelschlag so viel
Smith in der 54 Minute mit dem Ausgleich
und nur zwei Minuten später der
Siegtreffer durch Meloy piu das erste
Spiel gegen die Weltmeisterin hatte
Deutschland 2:1 gewonnen
der letzte Spieltag der
Fußball-Bundesliga VWM und Winterpause
endete gestern Abend mit einem furiosen
4:1-sieg der Freiburger gegen Union
Berlin der SC jetzt als Tabellen zweiter
und vier Punkten Abstand auf München
Bayern-Jäger Nummer eins
Mann des Spiels war dabei Freiburgs
Vincenzo Grifo mit einem Hattrick in den
ersten 20 Minuten er verwandelte unter
anderem zwei Elfmeter den ersten in der
vierten Minute in der sechsten musste
einen Querpass nur Einschieben in der 20
Minute noch mal der Italiener sicher vom
Punkt der Gästetrainer Fischer mochte da
schon nicht mehr hinschauen sein Team
nur noch zu zehnt und vorher schon mit
einem Elfmeter Fehlversuch Gregoritsch
noch vor der Pause mit dem 4:0
unionsmichel mit dem Ehrentreffer
kurzverschluss auch per Strafstoß Mann
des Spiels aber war Vincenzo Grifo
und alle Höhepunkte des letzten
bundesligaspieltags zusammengefasst bei
heute.de und in der ZDF heute-app vielen
Dank das Wetter wird wechselhafter mehr
dazu gleich von ostentherly Christian
Sievers begrüßt sie im heute journal um
viertel vor zehn machen sie sich noch
einen schönen Abend bis morgen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter morgen ist die
erste Hälfte des Monats um uns die war
viel zu warm ja und zu milde Luft
erreicht uns noch einmal von Südwesten
her ja aber Regen ist auch dabei sehen
ist hier es wird nicht viel sein zum
morgigen Abend dann weiter Regen aus
westlichen Richtungen in der Nacht
regnet es dann etwas im Westen viel wird
es nicht sein nach Osten in bildet sich
Nebel genauso wie Richtung Donau in
Bayern und das bei tiefsten Temperaturen
dort bis -1 Grad also leichter Frost und
neun Grad am Niederrhein das ist die
Temperatur Spanne morgen dann etwas
Regen der weiter Richtung Thüringen
zieht dann wird es vorübergehend etwas
trockener zum Spätnachmittag und Abend
kommt neuer Regen aus dem Südwesten an
ganz im Osten merkt man nichts davon da
scheint die Sonne bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 15 Grad Richtung
Thüringen oder Niederrhein 9 Grad mit 9
Grad ist es dann am kühlsten am
Alpenrand die nächsten Tage ja in der
Nacht auf Mittwoch kommt schon kräftiger
Regen von Westen auf der verlagert sich
im Tagesverlauf ostwärts bei 7 bis 15
Grad und Freitag gibt es im Osten sogar
einige Schneeflocken schönen Abend